he's one of the all-time greats not just
playing basketball but in his
broadcasting career courtesy of frosted
flakes here on the rich eisen show is
the great shaquille o'neal how are you
shaq i'm i'm i'm good now that i'm
talking to a legend how are you doing
[Laughter]
you say that to all the people you zoom
with actually i don't i want to say two
more things one i miss you and two i
love you sir two things right back at
you i miss you and i love you as well um
let's let's just jump right into it here
um
it's nfl opening week um you're still
cowboy fan you're still watching always
what do you think
i think uh listen we just got to go in
and put it on work and we got to get
back to being
america's team right we've we've
struggled in past couple years injuries
and
you know contract negotiations but you
know hopefully everybody's healthy and
look i'm a cowboys fan forever so right
she wanted to go see great brother i got
the opportunity to sit down like i
always see jerry jones passing high
right i got the opportunity to sit down
in his office that's a beautiful man
beautiful man you know he told me how he
started the cowboys his story is just so
legendary so
mr jones i know you're watching and talk
to him in the sun that was probably one
of the best days of my life well he it's
funny he said um last year he said that
prior to his third super bowl win
he said he told god if you give this to
me i won't ask for another and he's like
well i'm letting him know i'd like to
rearrange that deal
he's back to ask for another one yes you
know and
and i just love dak i love everything
about him i just love you know the way
he came in the league and the pressures
that he
he was under and then last year i mean
my god he was just bawling out and then
carted off and now he's back
good looking no worse to wear so this is
it right now you know
i wish them well i actually wish all the
other teams well
uh tampa bay gonna be bringing that
noise i could do my main man linda
fournette lsu had a great season that's
right that's lsu yeah so but uh i'm i'm
a cowboys guy so uh did you ever try it
did you ever try football you ever
played tight enough
i i was actually a great tight end okay
guy you're in a guy your size after i
scored so i sideswiped me messed my knee
up
and then i was just sitting at the house
one day you know just messing around and
my father came in with a piece of paper
and smacked me on the head
and he said if you he said i know you
like football but look what the
basketball players are making up this
was when john koncak signed that big
contract and that day right there i said
you know what no more football for me
i'm just going to bring this nfl style
to the nba
so somebody chopped you down went low
just that's what you do on the side yeah
it's your size yeah your size a little
scrawny little guy
trying to end my high school football
career and your dad's like you go get
yourself some concact money that's what
he's facing exactly yeah i mean because
you know i always tell people this
my dream was to make 8 million for 10
years that was my whole dream that was
my whole goal
and like i told my father that and he
was like uh i know what your dream was
but look what this john conkert guy's
making and i was like huh
i was like oh my jeez
now the rest is literally history um
and so uh okay
let's just hit the nba a little bit in
the time that i have with you here what
do you think of ben simmons um and his
situation in philadelphia that seems
uh like that marriage is going to have
to break up with whatever that's saying
going back to what my father taught me
he took me to a game one time it was a
terrible game and
on the way back he said son if you ever
make it to this level make sure you put
on a good show
you're obligated to do that
and i got i've never thought about it
but
we
are obligated to put on a good show
they're paying us 30 and like i put
myself in the category they're paying us
20 30 million to dribble a basketball
right put on a good show
work on your game they're asking you to
work on your game they're not they're
not saying nothing look nobody's saying
you're a bad guy you're doing this and
doing that we're saying that the process
is over
we brought we built this team to win
championships you know people in
philadelphia they respect people that
work hard
you got to work on your game i was there
at the game six where he dribbled under
the rim where he could have dunked it
because he didn't want to get fouled
listen i wasn't a great free throw
shooter but you know what
i wasn't going to stop being aggressive
because i was worried about missing free
throws
so we're obligated to put on a good show
we're obligated to work on our game so
he has to decide himself do i want to be
a really good player or do i want to be
one of the greatest
because you know it just sounds good but
it's a thin line like you know some
people are just happy with hey i'm
making 30 up i'm doing this i got this
actress i'm riding around in this car
some people were happy with that but
other people are like no
i want rich eyes and talking about me in
the morning saying i'm one of the
greatest ever so no he has to he has to
make that decision but
look i know he's receiving a lot of
criticism and the greats receive
criticism nobody's given up to where
they can't receive criticism but his
criticism is warranted work on your game
shoot the jumper step up to the line and
knock them down when you're supposed to
period there's nothing to talk about so
you know the fact that he said he wants
to be treated well he needs to
understand that if you don't work on
your game and you know he probably does
i'm not going to jump on him he probably
doesn't work on his game but
if you continue to to show up like you
did in the playoffs in any other arena
it's going to be the same thing down the
line so work on your game period yeah
obviously to do that it seems like
philly and he just can't mix anymore
right i mean do you think that
well it ain't got nothing to do with
philly
you know like i've been well we've both
been around you know in certain
circumstances oh
the you know the comp is is done i don't
want to be here anymore but this is all
on him
the people in philly have given them
enough chances and look philadelphia
boston l.a miami you got to bring it you
got to work hard and because the people
are watching people expect you to you
know work hard and he's been doing the
same thing for three four years and
they've given him a pass so
uh if he if he does come back there
his game better be different i know that
a few more minutes left with shaquille
o'neal here on the rich eisen show via
zoom let's go two hours with me rich you
know that i appreciate that i i don't
want to hold up your time on your on
your tour here shaquille o'neal i want
to make sure i'm respectful i'm
respectful about it
uh so um
what do you think damian lillard should
do what do you think is going on in his
mind and what you think
he's going to do or should let's go
start with this should do what do you
think he's an old school mentality guy
yes that's playing in the new school
see the old school guy will say
i'm not teaming up with you i'm going to
beat you
right but these new school guys are
saying hey let's team up to make it
easier so that's the toughest decision
for him i know he wants to stay in
portland and
you know win it out but he may have to
you may have to switch up his mentality
i'm not saying he should i'm just saying
he may have to because
everybody else is doing it and if
everybody else is doing it that's just
gonna
you know
keep him further from
winning a championship
uh so i mean but i i don't know like if
should he go to a contender if he wants
to
if he wants to
brighten his chance of winning a
championship i'd say he should do that
um i don't really
like
guys teaming up but it's just the way it
is these days and we just have to accept
it so
you know if we can get to a team that
already has two or three guys you add
him
that raises his chances of winning a
championship and i guess then
milwaukee's the old school way of doing
it then is that what you would think yes
yes i've heard y'all see on many
occasions i'm not going nowhere i'm
staying in milwaukee
and of course it'll be a lot of oh well
if
you know uh kawhi wasn't hurt and if
james wasn't hurt they wouldn't have won
maybe so but
giannis has said it i'm staying in
milwaukee they just gave him that big
money and i respect him for that
all right so tell me what you're doing
with um
with frosted flakes here shaq and how we
can help
earlier this year tony and i we teamed
up to take uh mission tiger to a whole
new level you know we want to help more
kids by uh
you know we have created this cereal uh
let's see let's make sure you get a good
look at it okay
there it is hello frosted flakes with
the crispy cinnamon balls
that's right okay and now
yes thanks all the fans who bought a box
tony and i are able to do something
bigger
uh with the game changing mission tiger
donation we're going to impact more than
60 000 kids
across school school districts in the
six cities that i played in and with
this money we're going to help kids
purchase new sports equipment uniforms
repave sports cars refurbish playing
fields and provide new training
equipment and more
the donations are part of mission tigers
goal that tony and i announced earlier
we said we're going to help a middle
school a million middle school teenagers
gain better access to sports and to date
we helped over 760 that's awesome
that's fantastic is there any way that
we can how can i help anything i can do
other than just buying your cereal and
eating cinnamon basketballs and stuff
like that well that's the cereal buy it
for your whole staff
because the lemon juice is really good
trust me well i like that it stays
crispy it's
crispy in milk i mean that's a crucial
that's a crucial part of it frosted
flakes is already the best cereal ever
but now this is the bestest
cereal everest
cereal everest i love it i love it well
okay well then i'm i'm thrilled to hear
that you're a good man shaquille o'neal
you're a good man i'm glad you're here
all right let's let's do this more often
um let me know brother you know i got
you i will hit you uh i will hit you uh
as conditions warrant for sure my wife
sends her bust you take care of yourself
shaquille o'neal uh would you like to
make a super bowl bet now
um on what on the hood just put
whoever you got the dallas uh i i dallas
cowboys are making it to super that is a
large amount of money there so i bet
this much versus your one dollar
that the dallas cowboys are making the
super bowl yes
oh my gosh okay well place that aside
place that aside as you know i'm this is
just this is just you know me talking
here as a national football league
employee i i don't understand what
you're asking me or anything like that
you understand what i'm saying but for
just for my friends just for you know
what's in giggles um keep that aside and
when we're off the air we can chit-chat
a little bit i i'm taking brady i'm
going brady again okay listen i love
brady uh uh i love those of you sure
love em all
so that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
stick with that and you and i will talk
soon shaquille o'neal let's let's do it
brother that's shaquille o'neal right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here